يوسف فادي رولا حبيبه وروبر
[موسيقى]
مجموعه من الاصدقاء الموهوبين يملكون
اصواتا غنائيه جيده وينشروها عالمهم على
حساباتهم الشخصيه ولهم محبين ومتابعين
لكن قرر يوسف اسماعيل جمعه تلك الاصوات
معنا او معا في فرقه موسيقيه اطلقوا
الفرقه التي انطلقت في اواخر فبراير
الماضي وصل مجموع متابعيها اليوم عبر
انستقرام وتيك توك ما يقارب 200 الف متابع
وهم اليوم ضيوف وقفتنا المسائيه في مساء
العربيه
[موسيقى]
في مساء العربيه رمضان كريم
رمضان كريم اهلا بكم وشكرا جدا على
الاستضافه الحلوه اهلا بكم اولا عندنا
فضول نعرف كيف تشكلت الفقره الفرقه في
الاول
ازاي تشكلت الفرقه احنا مؤخرا بقينا بنبص
على السوشيال ميديا وبنلاقي حاجات دمها
تقيل واخبار
دمها تقيل شويه والترندات مش لطيفه فحبينا
ان احنا نعمل حاجه
الترفيهيه تبسط الناس بشكل كويس ونعمل
ترند بس بحاجه لطيفه يعني فاتجمعنا واحنا
اصلا كلنا اصحاب يعني ولا ايه حلوه الفكره
بس احنا اصلا صحاب من قبل اي حاجه وبعدين
اتجمعنا على المزيكا يعني الله يخليكم
لبعض دائما يوسف الفكره كتير حلوه وجميله
لكن صعب انه تقدروا دائما تتجمعوا وتتفقوا
سواء على طريقه لحن معين او اطفاء روح
غنائيه معينه مثلا لاغنيه لانه انتم عم
تحكوا عن اكثر من شخص وشخصين
[موسيقى]
هي دي حقيقه هو دي اكشن من الحاجات اللي
بتواجهنا يعني الصعوبات فيها ان احنا كلنا
نتجمع مع بعض الايام اللي هنتجمع فيها
الطريقه اللي هنعمل بها الاغاني كل حد
اكيد بيبقى عنده مختلفه عن التاني بس اظن
الحاجه اللي بتخلينا نوصل لحاجه حلوه في
الاخر ان احنا كلنا اصحاب من قبل اي حاجه
يعني من قبل ما نعمل اتامبو يعني تقريبا
انت وحبيبه تعرفوا بعض من انا عندي 11 سنه
مثلا كنا مع بعض
[ضحك]
بقى لنا كتير قوي لما عملنا الموضوع ده
كان فيه ما بينا صداقه وفاهمين بعض
الميوزكري او فاهمين بعض موسيقيا فكان
الموضوع سهل بالنسبه لنا ان احنا نعمل
شغله الانسجام دائما بينكم هو بينعكس
فكمان احنا حابين نشوف انعكاس هذا
الانسجام وهذه الصداقه اللي بتجمعكم من
خلال اغنيه سمعونا اياها شو حابين تسمعونا
هلا بمناسبه شهر رمضان
نغني ايه اكتر اغنيه جابت فيوز لحد دلوقتي
عندنا لحد دلوقتي احنا طيب احنا كنا عملنا
ميدلي جميل كده الاغاني لست فيروز من اكثر
الاورتيز الهمونا كل احد فينا في حياتنا
فهنغنيهلكم يا رب يعجبكم
[موسيقى]
كان زمان
يبقى حنا الذكرى الدكان
[موسيقى]
العربي
انا
احبك من قلبي يا قلبي انت يا عينيا
[موسيقى]
يسلم هالصوت يعطيكم الف عافيه
ونورتونا اليوم بمسائل العربيه وان شاء
الله كمان بنشوفكم احلى واحلى شكرا لفرقه
معنا من القاهره احنا كنا مبسوطين قوي
[موسيقى]